hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about the
metric system the metric system is the
world standard for measurements it is
the system of measurements that is used
by scientists all around the world and
it's been adopted by most countries
unfortunately the United States is not
one that has adopted the metric system
for official use which means in the
United States we are often having to
convert between the u.s. system of
measurements and the metric system of
measurements so the metric system has
units for various types of measurements
including length volume mass and
temperature for length the meter is used
and it is abbreviated with an M for
volume the leader is used abbreviated
with an L mass it's the gram abbreviated
with a G and for temperature degrees
Celsius is used abbreviated as degrees
with a C now the interesting thing that
the metric system is that these base
units are used for these different kinds
of measurements and prefixes are
employed in order to get the right size
of unit there are various different
prefixes only a few of them are shown
here but these are the most common ones
there's Giga which is ten to the ninth
mega which is 10 to the sixth
of course we're most often hearing Giga
and mega used in computer terminology
for example we've all heard of gigabytes
and megabytes kilo is 10 to the third
for example when we talk about
out a 5k that is using the K from
kilometer to show the approximate level
of distance centi is 10 to the minus 2
note here that the exponent is negative
because using prefix centi is smaller
than the base unit whereas these first
three prefixes may be unit bigger than
the base unit milli is getting even
smaller at 10 to the minus 3rd micro
even smaller at 10 to the minus 6 nano
and pico getting even smaller at 10 to
the minus 9 and 10 to the minus 12
also note that each of these prefixes
have abbreviations Capital G capital M
lowercase K lowercase C lowercase M here
from micro the abbreviation is the Greek
letter nu you can also see in C uses the
abbreviation for micro and then
lowercase n and lowercase P rounding it
out for the Nano and picot prefixes now
let's look at some examples of how these
prefixes are added to these base units
to give a certain measurement so for
example if you are measuring the mass of
something you're using grams and it is
four times ten to the third or four
thousand instead of writing 4,000 grams
you could use the prefix for 10 to the
third which is kilo and this would be 4
kilograms 6 times 10 to the minus 9
liters instead of writing out this very
small number and standard notation you
can use the prefix for 10 to the minus
minus ninth which is nano so this would
be 6
nano liters which is obviously a very
small unit of volume here we have point
zero zero one grams this is the same as
10 to the minus third
prefix for that is Nelly so this is one
milligram here's another one five times
ten to the third again the prefix for
ten to the third is kilo so this would
be five kilometers and of course all of
you runners out there know that five
kilometers is a 5k a common type of
distance run so these are examples of
how these prefixes the K the end the M
and the K can be added in front of the
base units for things like graham liter
and meter in order to better explain
certain types of measurements you will
notice that it's rare for these prefixes
to be used with temperature simply
because the temperature scale itself
doesn't really lend itself well to these
kinds of prefixes mainly because we're
not using huge huge numbers or very very
small numbers they're all pretty much
within the range that can be stated
without the use of a prefix but there
are many places where meters leaders and
grams need these various prefixes to
help us understand those measurements as
we saw here so that is it for this video
on the metric system thanks for watching
biology professor and I hope you learned
a lot